[APPLAUSE]
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Thanks, guys.
Oh, I'm happy to be here.
And you guys can guess which is
the most challenging out of all
those accomplishments.
It's the kids.
Five kids is-- well, just
for instance, just a snapshot
of my life is this morning.
I wake up to a child crawling
in bed, second later,
my wife, who has been sick for
three days, lost her voice--
and now, I'm up here, right?
And she says Kacey, he
smells like throw up.
And so then, you've got to
go take care of the throw up
in the kid's bed.
And that was just this morning.
But that's every day--
something different
every day in my life.
I'm super excited to be here.
Disability is such
an interesting work
because it encompasses
so many things.
And for so much of
my life, I did not
want to be considered
in that category
because "disabled" meant
you couldn't do stuff.
And that was not me.
I was never that way.
And I probably should stop
going in that direction
because I need to
start at the beginning.
It's awesome going into
schools because kids--
and I was just in
one yesterday-- kids
will come right up to me, and
they'll just kind of look.
What happened?
Really loud.
And I love that about kids.
They're so interested.
And sometimes, as adults,
we live in this PC world.
You know, you can't ask
or can't do anything
that might be offensive.
But kids, they don't have that,
and they're insatiably curious.
And so I love it.
So I look at them and I go,
well, I don't have any legs.
They're like, why?
And very seriously, I'll look
at them and say, a squirrel.
[MOCK SCREAM]
[MAKES SOUND OF CAR RACING OFF]
But that's not what happened.
When I was six years old, I
grew up in a little small town
called Kemmerer, Wyoming.
Has anybody ever heard
of-- yeah, exactly.
It's a really small town.
Well, when I was
six, we went down
to Utah, another small town.
My uncle was going
on a mission trip,
and so we went down
to see him off.
Well, after the church
services were over,
we were standing on
the edge of the road.
Now, it was December, December
20th in Utah, so pretty cold,
snow everywhere,
and we were standing
on the edge of a
divided highway.
So there's just
one lane each way.
Well, as I'm standing there
next to my mom and my dad right
by my side, they said,
OK, Kacey, there's
two cars coming in a truck.
Well, as any good
six-year-old does,
I looked one way at the
two cars that went by me,
but I forgot to
look the other way
and, instead, started
sprinting across the road.
I don't remember what happened.
I don't know if I didn't
hear about the truck
or I just went anyway, but I
sprinted across a road right
in front of the truck.
Now, it wasn't just
a pickup truck.
It was a semi truck that
was barreling down on me.
And I ran right in front of it.
At the last second, I even
drove to get out of the way.
But the truck was
able to clip my legs
and rolling me beneath
the wheels right there,
as my parents watched.
Some of you are parents.
You can imagine that
horrible feeling.
But truck stops,
my dad rushes over,
and I'm laying
there on the road.
And when he gets
to me, my left leg
had been completely
severed by the semi truck,
and they later found it
between two of the wheels.
I got a little bit
of stub left, which
is good for wrestling and doing
movies called "Fear the Stub--"
that I'll be great.
Hey, if there's five Sharknados,
I think "Fear the Stub--"
Hiyaa!
[MAKES KUNG FU SOUNDS]
Fear the Stub!
You guys are like, is it out?
When can I see this?
No, it's not.
I've got to get funding.
But my right leg was still--
well, it was kind of attached.
It was beaten up pretty good,
but it was still kind of there.
Well, my dad holds
me and talks to me.
You know, what do you
want for Christmas?
And just kept me going
until the ambulance was
able to get there and
rush me to the hospital--
the local hospital.
It was pretty small.
I don't know what happened
when they wheeled me
into the operating room.
I assume the doctors just
looked at me and was like,
I don't think the
big Band-Aid's going
to cover this one I don't know.
But they weren't able
to help me there.
And so they had to fly
me to Salt Lake City.
And it was Utah
through a blizzard.
So that was nice.
I really don't remember.
I remember as they loaded me
out of the helicopter on top
of the hospital, I
remember laying there
on the stretcher filling
the [MAKES SOUND EFFECT]
of the helicopter and my
one thought was, it's cold.
That was it.
That was my first thought.
It wasn't until much later
when I woke up that I found out
I didn't have legs.
But they rushed me
into the hospital,
and my right side was so
damaged they told my parents,
OK, we might be able
to save his leg,
but it's going to require
dozens of surgeries,
and he may never be able to
use it throughout his life.
And my mom said, well,
that's an easy decision.
He can live without legs.
Amputate his leg.
And so they amputated
my right side.
Besides the whole
not-having-legs thing,
I really didn't have
that many injuries.
I broke my right elbow,
I split my tongue--
I knocked out a bunch of teeth.
I have a nice little bald
spot right there on the back.
I know some of you are
sporting your own more up here.
So I had a few injuries.
So as a six-year-old, one
of them was so confusing.
I had this big cut
right down the center.
And I'm like, Mom,
what's that from?
And they said, well,
they had to cut
you open to see if
you were bleeding.
In my mind, I just
imagined the doctor,
like, he started to cut.
And the nurse goes,
doctor, he's bleeding.
And the doctor's like, I
know, and keeps cutting.
And the nurse is like,
he's still bleeding!
Like, I know!
And he keeps cutting.
And I didn't know.
But now, I understand
they had to make
sure the inside stuff was good.
And luckily, it was.
Ooh, I also have one right here.
And I always tell the
middle-schoolers this one.
This is from a colostomy.
You guys know what that is?
It's when they take your
rectum, and they move it.
That was probably one
of the worst things,
to have to sit there with your
rectum on your stomach and poop
into a bag.
But there was there
was a silver lining.
You've got to look
for the good, right?
I have brothers.
So not only did I poop in the
bag, I also farted in the bag.
And as anybody with
brothers knows,
that's a powerful weapon
to be able to store
your farts for your brother.
Well, it wasn't very
long until I was
ready to leave the hospital.
And as I was leaving
the hospital,
the doctors told my
parents something
that would change
the rest of my life--
that would be very important.
They told my parents
not to do stuff for me.
OK, now, you have
this six-year-old.
You have this little
six-year-old--
he was a little
six-year-old; now, he's
a really little six-year-old.
Why would the
doctors, the people
that should be
taking care of me,
tell my parents not
to do stuff for me?
Why would they say that?
This is the audience
participation part of it.
Yeah, why would they do that?
To force you to learn to
do stuff for yourself?
Exactly!
I had to learn how
to do stuff myself.
I see a lot of--
sorry for the air quotes--
"disabled people," and they
live their lives disabledly?
Disabilitedly?
They lived like they're
disabled because they
let other people do things
that they very well could
do on their own.
When I got home--
this is a cool
Uncle Kurt story--
when I got home,
I was in my room
sitting-- you can imagine
this is the floor.
If I sat down there,
you couldn't see me.
So I was in my room, and I
want to show my Uncle Kurt
something.
So I'm like, Hey Uncle
Kurt, turn on the light.
Well, my dad, taking this lesson
from the doctors to heart,
slaps his hand away and
said, don't you dare.
Like that.
And my Uncle Kurt turns
around like, Bernie,
stopped being a jerk!
I'm just going to
turn on the light.
He's like Kurt, don't
you turn on the light.
He has to do it.
And my mom Uncle Kurt got mad
at my dad and said, Bernie!
You're being stupid.
Let me turn on the light.
And my dad's like, no.
And so I looked around the room,
and I had to figure it out.
I looked around the room
and, I found a baseball bat.
And I'm like, dad.
And I went over to the
light, and I used the bat
to turn on the light.
And that was just one
little example of the things
I had to figure out
throughout my life.
Very soon after getting home,
I wanted to start doing sports.
Well, the next sport up was
Little League, was tee ball.
And I was in my little
hospital wheelchair thing.
And my dad--
I was pretty weak
still, so my dad
would push me around the bases.
Now, I don't know
your dad's, but my dad
is extremely
competitive, especially
when it comes to baseball.
So little six-year-old me
would hit the ball, pew!
And then, my dad would push me.
[MAKES SOUND EFFECT] And
I'm sitting there going,
[SCREAM] slow down!
No, we're going to win!
[GIGGLE] I'm going to die!
Well, the next year,
though, the next year,
I decided that I didn't want my
dad pushing me around anymore.
So I decided to get
out of my wheelchair
and start playing
from the ground.
Now, I won't be able
to run that far--
right off the edge--
but I found that if
I hit left-handed,
I was like a foot
closer to first base.
So I would hit the ball.
And then-- I'll
pantomime my running--
that's a horrible run--
you'll see it in
the video later.
But then, I'd run to first
base on my hands and on my but.
Now, I wasn't very fast,
and I got out a lot,
but I was out there playing.
I was out there doing
stuff that, honestly,
should have been impossible.
How does a guy without
legs play baseball?
Well, I figured it out.
I was in elementary, and I had
to do all those PE things--
I had to figure out
how to do push-ups!
How do you do push-ups when
you're in a wheelchair?
Well, my first attempt
went something like this.
I got out of my
chair, and I started
doing push-ups like this.
And I thought I was awesome.
Because I could do,
like, a million of them.
But like, can you
do a clap push-up.
Oh, yeah.
Well, after a while, though,
I started getting into sports,
and I wanted to get stronger.
I wanted to be able to
do some harder push.
And so I started doing
push-ups like this.
And so I started
figuring out how
to challenge myself
and push myself.
And then, I got into wrestling.
Hold on.
I've got to tuck this in.
I don't want to show off my
My Little Pony underwear.
That would be embarrassing.
You guys are like,
uh, that's creepy.
The kid thought it
was funny, all right?
All right, so I started
doing push-ups like this.
I had to figure out how to
challenge myself and push
myself.
I mean, yeah, it's nice
to say I was doing things.
But even more than that,
I wanted to be successful.
Well, growing up in
a house full of boys,
I had three brothers
and one sisters.
We were playing sports all
the time, and one of them
was basketball.
I mean, this was the
era of Michael Jordan,
Scottie Pippin, Dennis Rodman--
we were Bulls fans--
or, I was, at least.
And we all wanted to be
the next Michael Jordan.
Well, I decided that I was
going to try out for basketball.
Well, I went down to the league
and my brother was trying out.
And we did it.
I would dribble the ball.
I wasn't good at
shooting the ball,
but I would dribble, and
steal, and run the whatevers,
and do the things.
And afterwards, the directors
came up to my parents,
and they said we recommend
Kacey doesn't play basketball.
My parents were like,
OK, he wants to play.
Let him play.
They're like, well, we're
afraid he'll get hurt.
My mom's, like, oh,
that's all right.
She probably said something
along the lines of, um,
he's tougher than you are.
Let him play.
Basically, they didn't
want to get sued,
and I didn't get
to play that year.
Well, the next year,
there was new directors,
and I tried again.
But once again, I was
told, no, you cannot play.
Now ladies and gentlemen, in our
lives-- throughout your lives,
you've had times
like this, and you're
going to have more times like
this, where someone is going
to tell you what you can't do.
Maybe, honestly, now
that we're adults,
it's going to be you that tells
yourself what you can't do.
And instead of
listening to that-- now,
very easily I could
have put myself
in the box they called "cripples
can't play basketball."
I could have put
myself in that box
and not been able
to play basketball.
But instead of that, I went to
another league, Boys and Girls
Club, rolled up to the
desk and said, hey,
can I play basketball?
To which they responded,
yeah, we let everybody play.
Like, what?
And so I played basketball.
I wasn't great.
But I was able to play--
made like three baskets
the whole year, but I played.
Well, later on, I get
into eighth grade,
and I have this
experience again.
I wanted to do cross country.
Any runners out here?
Couple of you?
So cross country is not--
it's not on a track.
It's not running trail--
well, it is running
trails, but these are--
especially here in the
Northwest-- you got mud, dirt,
grass--
running through the
trees, it's pretty crazy.
And this was the
first time in my life
my parents kind of
questioned my life choices.
They're like,
Kacey, there's mud.
I'm like, I know!
Kacey, you're in a wheelchair.
Yes!
They're like, Kacey, that's
going to be really hard.
I know.
It's a challenge.
And then my dad, of course,
looks at me and goes,
well, if you start it,
you've got to finish it.
I'm like, yeah, I know.
And so I went in.
I turned the form in.
And then, I got called
down to the office.
And I don't know if you've
ever had this situation where
you sit down, and there's
like five adults just staring
at you.
You guys are like,
I hate that now.
But as a little eighth grader,
my voice was still changing,
and they're just staring at me.
I was a little freaked out.
They're like, Kacey, why do
you want to do cross country?
I thought it would be fun.
Well, Kacey, it's
going to be hard.
Yeah, my mom said
there would be mud.
And I said, I could do it.
I wasn't very eloquent.
And they were like,
Kacey, we recommend
you don't do cross country.
Oh, OK.
Can I do football?
Now, I don't know what they were
thinking, but they said yes!
I don't know where cross
country is dangerous
and football is safe.
You know, cross
country, there's--
trees.
Football, it's safe.
We'll give him a helmet!
So they put me in
the safest place--
in football, defensive line,
right there on the front.
It was great, though because
I was nice and short.
So the guys with
the ball, they'd
come running right at me.
They couldn't see me at all.
I'd grab them-- boom!
Yeah!
Except I was an eighth-grade
boy, and so I was like,
[HIGH-PITCHED VOICE]
yeah, what now?
What now?
Well, the next year, though,
I got into high school,
and I decided, you know what?
I am going to show them
that I can do cross country.
So I went to the office--
said, hey, can I
do cross country?
To which they replied, as
long as you sign the waiver.
If you die, we don't care.
And they let me
do cross country.
Now, I wasn't fast.
I was last almost
every single race,
but I finished
every single race.
One race was called "trask."
They run you through the mud.
They run you through rivers.
They run you through
these deep mud pits
where I would sync
up to my neck.
But I finished
every single race.
Well, year after year, I got
faster, and I got better.
Until my senior
year, I was actually
so fast that I was actually
beating the top runners
at the races I went to.
In fact, I eventually won the
district meet of my league.
Now you think with
that big of a switch,
OK, here's a guy that
can do anything--
you know what I mean?
He's last, very last.
He's doing it.
That's great.
That's inspirational.
And now, he's fast.
Well, there is a lot of people
that looked at that as unfair.
It wasn't unfair
when I was slow.
But now, it was.
And so they actually didn't
let me run the state meet.
The reasoning is great--
because it wasn't
designed for wheelchairs.
No cross-country
courses, it's all
through the mud, and through
the trails, and grass,
and up and down
hills, so no course
is great for wheelchairs.
But I was able to do that.
Well, I did other sports.
I wrestled.
I eventually took second
place in state for wrestling.
I did track as well
doing distance racing,
and that actually is
what led me to college,
where I started doing
wheelchair racing in college.
I started track, and
I got into marathons.
Now, marathons, they seem crazy,
and they are kind of crazy.
And the people that
do them are crazy.
And I started doing them in
college, but what was crazy
is I loved them.
So I guess that
describes me right there.
And I started doing marathons.
In fact, I beat my coach
at a few marathons.
Well, after a year
in college, I went
on a mission for my church,
and then afterwards came back
and started racing
marathons again.
Well, after a while,
though, I realized-- now,
this sounds crazy,
but after a while,
I realized that marathons had
no more challenge because it was
just 26 miles--
and I wanted to
challenge myself.
I wanted to see what I could do.
So often in media and when
you see people in wheelchairs,
it's always looked at
as, what they can't do.
Well, I wanted to show--
and I had started this
motivational speaking company,
and I wanted to show
people what was possible.
I wanted to show
people what I could do
and, hopefully,
what they could do.
Take away those excuses that we
all put on ourselves every day.
Every day we put an excuse--
why we can't work out
that day, why we can't--
take your pick.
You have your own
challenges in life.
And so I wanted to do something
to strip away those excuses.
Well, I started looking
for a challenge--
started looking for a challenge.
And then, one day, I see this
race called "Spartan Race."
Who has heard of the
Spartan Race before?
All right, a few of you.
So let me describe it.
You take a cross-country course.
We're talking through the
woods, mud, everything.
You take one of those courses,
and then you add obstacles--
like rope climb, fire
jump, bucket carry,
sandbag carry-- you had
all these obstacles,
these crazy obstacles, and
that's called a "Spartan Race."
Well, guys, I
looked at this race,
and my first thought was,
OK, that's impossible.
That's insane.
That's so stupid.
There's no way that
a guy without legs
can do one of those things.
That's insane!
But it wasn't too long until
I realized, oh, OK, this
is exactly what I want to do.
I don't know if I can
finish it, but I'm
going to give it a shot.
And so I signed up
for the first one,
and it just about killed me.
It was awful.
I get done with the race,
and we're driving home.
My wife looks over and
says, well, that was fun.
I guess you can
cross that one off.
I was like, yeah, that was hard.
I want to do the next one.
She's like, no!
That one almost killed you!
A longer one will kill you!
I'm like, maybe!
But I want to do it anyway.
And so I did the next one, which
was twice as long, eight miles.
And then, I decided to do the
next one, which was 13 miles.
And then, I did
all three of them
in a year called the trifecta.
And every time, I'm
looking for a challenge.
I'm looking for
something to push me.
Because, guys, in our lives,
regardless of our situation,
regardless of our challenge--
and honestly, we all
have something that we
can claim disability on.
We all have a challenge
in life that slows us down
from accomplishing what
we want to accomplish.
Now, honestly, this
is not my disability.
I'm not disabled because
I'm in a wheelchair.
I have found a way to do
just about everything--
or, I found a way to do
everything that I want to do.
I have other
challenges for sure.
So as we look at this
thing called "disability--"
and I still don't
like that word.
I like "adaptive."
There's a big push right
now called "para athletes,"
adaptive athletic.
Has anybody seen
the Paralympics--
watch the Paralympics?
You watch those guys.
They are doing the exact same
sports, training just as hard
if not harder than
the Olympians,
because every single
one of the paralympians
has had some major
tragedy in their lives.
Now, each and every
one of us has either
had some major tragedy or
has known someone with that.
That's how we get stronger.
Let me tell you
about steel working--
like the old blacksmith
steel working.
The blacksmith would
take a hunk of iron--
usually, it's still rod,
and he'd put it in the fire.
Now the fire isn't what
makes the iron strong.
In fact, the fire makes it soft.
Heating up metal makes it soft.
That makes sense.
You have to be able to shape it.
Well, that iron comes
out of the fire,
and it's ready to be shaped.
Now, it needs to be hardened.
Now, if you just let
it cool, it would still
be a very soft metal, and
it would break very easily.
But what does a blacksmith
do after he pulls it out
of the fire?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Not quite.
What does he do
before quenching it?
AUDIENCE: Works it.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Works it!
But how does he work it?
AUDIENCE: With a hammer.
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
With a hammer!
He's pounding on that
thing, all right?
He is slamming it.
And I actually listen
to a book recently,
and it talked about
the hammering.
It actually changes the
structure of the metal.
Hammering it changes
the crystal structure
to make a stronger
and a tougher metal.
And I realized after hearing
that, that is exactly
like us in our lives.
Guys, that's kind of why--
at least, for me,
that's why I'm down here
on this Earth is to get
better and to get stronger,
not necessarily--
not necessarily these amazing
guns right here-- this, too.
But-- I just wanted
to show off here.
Let's just-- I don't
know how to pose.
OK, I mean, I'm not talking
about that kind of strength.
I'm talking about
the strength inside.
Because the more challenges
that we're able to get through,
the more challenges that
we're able to accomplish,
the stronger we'll
be-- and yeah,
physically, but also up here.
Once you've gone through
some crazy challenges,
the little things just
don't seem that bad anymore.
After dealing with
five kids when you're
kid climbs into your
bed covered in throw up,
that's just Friday morning
before you leave to Google.
That's just what life is.
But that is exactly what--
that's the change we need
to see in disabilities.
They are not a limiting factor.
Yeah, there may need
to be adaptations.
There may need to be
some accommodations
that, as we help people to
figure out what they can be,
we need to help them,
not enable them.
And I have a son who's
also in a wheelchair.
And so very often, we have to
balance what we do with him.
Are we enabling him?
Are we doing everything for him?
Now what can he do on his own?
And so as we look
at disabilities
in this new world
we're living in,
we need to see them
in a different light.
Disabilities are not "dis."
And I don't like it
started with the "dis"
because it sounds so negative.
Yeah, there's people
with challenges.
And it might be mental
challenges as well.
My oldest has ADHD and diagnosed
with autism as well, I think.
My second, he's autistic,
the next has a speech delay.
And the kid in a wheelchair,
we adopted him from Ukraine.
He spent the first
six years in a bed.
He has CP; he's blind.
So we have some amazing
diversity in our home,
but you wouldn't believe
what incredible kids
they are because
of their challenge,
they have the world in a
completely different light.
And I can see their strengths
because of their diversity.
I'm diverse physically.
My kids are diverse mentally.
We all have--
I see a lot of racial
diversity here.
Each and every one of
us brings something else
amazing to the table.
OK, now, after going
to that rant for a bit,
I want to show you
guys a Spartan Race.
Because this, honestly,
encompasses everything
that I've been talking about.
This talks about what really is
possible, but it also shows--
there's a few instances where
you'll see people helping me,
because I'm short.
And an eight-foot
wall is just so high.
And so I need help.
But you'll see challenges.
And the hardest one here
is the bucket brigade.
Now, think about it.
Before I even show this
to you, picture this.
80-pound bucket of just
a five-gallon bucket
filled with rocks.
Now, most of you probably
think that's a good challenge.
Maybe some of you think
that's a good workout.
But regardless, it's hard.
Take your legs off.
How do you move that bucket?
It's a challenge.
So let me go ahead
and start this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - IMAGINE DRAGONS, "RISE
UP"]
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Pretty cool, huh?
Who's ready to go do
a Spartan Race now?
Yeah, nice!
Nice!
They do kid Spartan Racing, so
you can go do Spartan Races.
April, they do a super.
And then, October, September,
October, they do a--
[INADVERTENTLY PLAYS VIDEO]
--that's another one--
--in Snohomish, so right
near you guys if you do
want to challenge yourself.
But that's our lives, guys.
We're going to have challenges.
Life is going to knock you
down face down into the mud.
And honestly, we're
going to have a choice.
You make the choice.
You either start playing in the
mud or you lay down and suffer.
And I've chosen to
play in the mud.
I'm a little kid at heart.
Well, I want to open it up to
questions for a little bit.
And then, I will-- ooh,
hey, a mic for the crowd.
That'd be great.
Please feel free
to ask questions.
Sometimes I'm disappointed
in adults, because you just
sit there and stare at me.
Kids are like, how do
you go to the bathroom!
I aim for the middle.
How do you go to the bathroom?
So go ahead and question away.
AUDIENCE: So I just
want to know how long it
took to do the Spartan Race?
Like, 13 miles is a long way.
I can run 13 miles,
but I have legs.
How long does that take?
Because that's going
to be even more
grueling, just because
it's just so long.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Well,
it depends on the terrain.
So if I'm just
out on the road, I
can do about 2 and 1/2 miles
an hour, which is pretty slow,
but you start adding
obstacles and stuff.
It slows me down last
April here in Snohomish.
It was as a bog.
It was muddy.
It took me a mile per hour.
It was eight hours
to finish that.
I just did one here in
Lake Tahoe, 13.5 miles,
but it's elevation.
We were climb and 4,000 feet,
and that took me 12 hours
to finish that 13.5 mile course.
AUDIENCE: That's so amazing.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm really inspired.
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
Oh, thank you.
Well, it's pretty
cool coming up--
yeah, we've got a
Spartan in the back.
Coming up, I am doing a 24-hour
Spartan Race in Iceland.
Yeah, it's going to be a
five-mile loop in near freezing
conditions.
So I am nervous, and excited,
and ready for that challenge.
I made the mistake, though.
The guy that started Spartan
Race-- name is Joe De Sena--
he was there in Tahoe,
and he saw me finish.
And after the race,
I looked at him
and I said, well,
Joe, I'm always
looking for a bigger challenge,
something to finally beat me,
and you haven't beat me yet.
And he's kind of crazy.
And he looks at me and
he's like, all right.
I'll beat you.
I'll find something.
So he invited me to this.
So I'll have to prove to him
I can keep going for 24 hours.
Did you have a--
AUDIENCE: How'd you get over the
fire without burning yourself?
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Is that an
awesome part of that video?
Yeah.
So I had no clue how
I was going to do it.
That fire jump was the first
fire jump I'd ever done.
Now I don't know if any of
you have been close to a fire.
But as you get closer,
the heat is not
contained right at the fire.
That's the beauty of a fire.
It radiates the heat.
Well, about from
here to those chairs,
I could feel this
blistering heat.
And it was so scary to
take those next steps just
to get up to the fire.
And without really
knowing what to do,
I found two places that
weren't burning as bad--
some non-burnt pieces of
wood, grabbed onto them--
and there was no choice.
I had to put my butt right
in the middle of the coals,
and I placed it, and got
out, and did one of these,
and made sure I wasn't burning.
So I've done a few
fire jumps since then.
But yeah, it's always
scary to do the fire jump.
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's very exciting.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Thank you.
Yeah, it's pretty awesome.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask a question.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So how much
training do you do,
and what does it look
like for these races?
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
That's a great question.
Well, with five kids, training
is always a challenge.
I mean, honestly,
I love training.
I love getting out and
exercising, which isn't--
a lot of people, I understand,
it's hard to get out.
I understand that, for me,
it's even more difficult
because I have little children.
And so my training-- my
hardest part of these races
is the walking.
Climbing up a cargo net?
Pretty easy.
Climbing up a rope?
Not easy, but I can
do it pretty simply.
Hauling rocks, it
takes strength,
but the hardest is
just the mileage.
And so when I workout,
I'm out there running.
Last night, I wasn't
able to get out there
till 9:45, pitch dark.
I kind of live out in the
country, so there's nothing.
It's pitch dark, scooting
down the middle of a road,
30-something degrees.
And about a mile from home,
I heard coyotes yelling.
So it was even more
exciting last night.
I kept turning around
looking for the little eyes
in the darkness.
And it was scary.
So a lot of running.
But I also spear.
They do a spear throw.
I'm horrible at the spear
throw, so I'm always
chucking a spear trying to
not have to do the burpees.
If you miss an obstacle-- some
of the other obstacle courses,
if you fail, you just
go to the next one.
Spartan Race, if you
fail an obstacle,
you have to do 30 burpees.
Well, mine aren't how they
really do it, by you squat,
you go plank push-up,
do a push-up,
and then you jump, and put
your hands over your head,
and that's one.
And you've got to do 30 of them.
So nobody likes doing
30 burpees, right?
AUDIENCE: So I'm a swimmer.
I'm curious.
I saw you did some
swimming stuff.
Can you share more about how
you train there and what you do?
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
Yeah, absolutely.
I don't do a ton of
swimming, but I love, like,
Ironman Triathlon
training, and so
I have trained a
lot of swimming.
I'm not super fast,
but I can do--
what is it-- is that 50 meters?
The pool?
I can do that in a minute.
So yeah, a decent pace.
It's a decent pace.
But I haven't done
a full Ironman.
I did a half Ironman
because I'm half of a man.
That's a stump slapper.
OK.
I have too many legless jokes.
So yeah, I love swimming.
I did a mile swim for the
half Ironman, plan on doing
a full Ironman one day.
So I like swimming.
It's good.
AUDIENCE: Tell us
about your gear.
Like, do you wear--
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Yeah, oh,
gear's a constant battle.
Well, nobody creates a boot
for a guy without legs,
and so I have had to--
I assume some of
your jobs, you have
to be very innovative
in what you do.
Well, I assume.
I don't know.
You guys are Google.
Google does everything.
So I assume you have
to create new things.
And that's what I have
to do all the time.
The boot I wear is
off of the design
that my mom did way back
when I was in high school,
and I've been refining it.
It's a simple, just,
sleeve with a bottom on it,
but I've had to actually--
right near here,
there's Seattle fabrics,
and they have everything.
So I went there.
They had waterproof vinyl.
And I used to sew it together,
but now I glue it together
to make it even more durable.
But every single time, every
single training run I go on,
I come up with a better
idea of how to work my boot
and how to make a better one.
And there's been a good
dozen different styles
and things I've done.
And that's just my boot.
Not only that, gloves
are a huge issue.
I usually wear mechanic gloves
because they have a good thing
on the thing, but--
thing on the thing.
Wow.
I'm a public speaker.
I do this for a job.
Thing on the thing.
Guard on the knuckles.
But it's a constant struggle
to find more padding.
Going to Iceland, it's
going to be wet and cold.
And if my hands get cold, it's
going to really slow me down.
So, yeah, gear.
Gear is a constant battle.
Even a backpack is a huge
issue because I'm doing this.
It scrapes right
there on my neck,
and so I've had to figure
out friction reduction.
My arms are doing
this, so I have
to figure out how to protect
my skin on different places.
Yeah, gear is a constant battle.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
about having children
with autism and ADHD.
What do you find is
effective for, I guess,
communicating and being
patient and positive?
And do you have an
approach that you
take to inspire them
and motivate them
to create a happy environment?
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Man, you're
asking the easy questions
today, right?
Oh, man.
Well, I am the perfect
parent, just ask--
no, I am not.
Is there a such thing?
Man, that's a hard
question right there.
Honestly, it's learning.
It is learning.
But you're right.
Being patient--
because kids are--
I mean, I remember
growing up, I'm like,
well, if you calmly explain to
a child, they'll understand.
I heard some laughs at that.
No, a child-- you
know, kids are kids.
Patience.
And parenting is the
great patience learner.
Kids are crazy.
They just are-- as one
is sitting-- hi, kid.
Hello.
But they're also awesome.
They'll learn.
They will learn.
And sometimes it's
going to take years.
My daughter-- extreme ADHD.
I mean, not like,
oh, little active--
like literally
bouncing-off-the-walls,
can't-sit-in-a-seat ADHD.
But we've, just, little
here and there, patience,
keep reinforcing--
never enabling,
never giving them excuses--
like, oh, you have ADHD.
You don't have to do this.
No, well, we're going to find
a way for you to take note.
We're going to find a
way for you to do this.
Autism, same thing.
My son he gets
overwhelmed by things.
OK, Patrick, how are we
going to deal with this?
OK, when you start
feeling like this,
let's this, and this, and this.
And of course, they
listen right away to that.
But patience.
It's all about patience and
just step by step, step by step.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
AUDIENCE: I was curious,
what's your diet like?
What are you drinking
and eating so you're not
experiencing muscle failure?
KACEY MCCALLISTER: You guys
are asking the worst questions.
I have five kids.
I eat whatever I can
throw in their faces.
Years ago, when I was really
training for wheelchair racing
and doing a lot of
marathons, I kept
reading these books
about these guys,
and they were only
eating plants.
They weren't eating meat.
And I'm like, oh,
that's horrible!
You've got to eat meat to be--
you've got to be strong!
You've got to eat meat!
And then, I realized,
I'm like, fine.
I'll try it.
And then, I went and
set the course record
on this race I did
right after that.
And I'm like, curse
you, people that
know what you're talking about.
So plant-based diet.
I love sweet potatoes,
and corn, and I
make some thing
called Ezekiel bread.
It just has a lot
of grains in it.
I'm not like, totally,
die-hard, no animal stuff--
I eat eggs, and some
milk, and stuff.
But mostly whole foods.
Whole foods.
Danielle took me to
the free restaurant.
It was a wonderful.
And like everywhere I looked,
it was just whole food--
especially the salad bar,
but the more processed
stuff you eat, the more junk
you're putting in your body.
You wouldn't put sand
in your gasoline tank;
why are you putting
McDonald's into your body?
It's not going to help you.
So given I'm not perfect on
that, I travel all the time--
I mean, it was a four-hour drive
up here, four-hour drive back,
you know?
It's always a
constant challenge--
constant challenge to eat right.
But the more I focus
on whole foods,
the more you can eat things
that are not heavily processed,
the better off
you're going to be.
And that helps you
in every aspect.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so it looks like
you've got a big focus on doing
able-bodied sports.
And I was wondering
if you've done
much with the disabled
sports, Paralympic sports
like basketball,
hockey, or wheelchair--
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Yeah, I have.
So I did wheelchair racing
in high school, college.
When I hit U of A in college,
they had wheelchair basketball.
Now I wrestled in high school.
If you know anything
about wrestlers,
we can't shoot the basketball.
We're like here,
and it's over there.
It doesn't work.
But they're, like, oh,
just come out for the team.
And I get out there
and I realized
how much-- especially
wheelchair basketball,
you really don't have
to touch the ball.
You just go--
[MAKES RACING SOUND EFFECT]----
zooming down the court.
I absolutely love
wheelchair basketball.
It's a blast.
But I've got to play around
with seated volleyball.
I found out that I'm freakin'
awesome at seated volleyball.
I'm amazing at that.
I love to do sled hockey.
Yeah, I do it when I can.
Absolutely.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I thought
I heard you mention
church, so I wanted
to ask, are you
a person of a particular faith?
KACEY MCCALLISTER: I am.
AUDIENCE: And has that
impacted your outlook?
Or were you ever angry at God?
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
I never got angry.
I am a person of faith.
I was brought up in a--
it's called the Church of
Jesus Christ of Latter Day
Saints-- brought up from birth.
And so I do have a very strong
spiritual aspect to my life.
And I talked about my
purpose here on earth.
I believe we all
have that purpose.
But I found that having that
spiritual outlook-- now,
whatever that be-- if you
have a religious outlook
or even if it's just a different
spiritual aspect to yourself,
as you look inward in
whatever way you do,
you're going to be able to
answer those hard questions
about yourself.
One of the most amazing
teachings that I follow,
it talks about being humble.
And we have these challenges.
We have weaknesses in life.
It's so that we can be humble.
And that's whatever spiritual
aspect you look at--
those weaknesses can actually
become your strengths.
For me, it's God.
For others, it's
different things.
As we rely on those
other strengths,
we can make those
weaknesses become strong.
And honestly, that's what I
believe we're down here to do.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today.
KACEY MCCALLISTER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You were
mentioning some challenges
while being a public speaker--
traveling, eating-- can
you tell us more about--
KACEY MCCALLISTER:
Yeah, well, I've
been doing this business
for three years now.
I was actually trained as
a teacher through college
because I wanted
to motivate youth.
I love the youth.
They have such potential.
But nowadays, man,
this right here?
This is horrible.
I know, I know, you
guys are Google.
You guys are like,
that's my living!
I know!
This is a Pixel 2.
I love Google.
But for teenagers, it's
a really hard challenge.
And so I love
motivating the youth,
and that's why I
became a teacher.
And so starting this
motivational speaking business,
I've been doing it, but
there are a lot of challenges
with health as I travel--
eating right-- exercising.
When you travel--
I drove four hours up.
I'm here four hours.
And then, I'm driving
four hours home.
When do I exercise?
Well, it'll be after
all the kids are in bed.
And I go out chasing
coyotes again tonight.
So, yeah, there's so many
challenges, just in this job.
It's traveling all the time--
figuring out, eating
right, figuring out
how to work while
you're traveling,
figuring out how to
do all that stuff.
Yeah, thank you.
Well, I was told to wrap it up.
So I'm so grateful to be here.
But before I leave,
I do want to--
this isn't just sitting
here randomly for no reason.
I know some people
who come in are
like, why is there a dirty
ladder in our conference room?
I brought it, and this
is the ladder I used.
A ladder is very much
like things in our lives.
And I'll give the example.
I just finished
writing my book--
plug for my book--
it's coming out in April--
look for it on social media--
plug for social media.
Our lives and our challenges
are very much like a ladder.
As we start on those challenges,
they may seem impossible.
I mean, how does a guy
without legs climb a ladder?
Well, for me, it was,
how do I write a book?
And I'm awful.
I was awful at writing.
But how do you do it?
It's one step at a time.
And as we take
that first step, we
realize that that next
step is going to be hard,
but it's as hard
as the last one.
And as we continue on
through that challenge,
we take one step at a time.
And it might be so challenging,
as you watched in the video,
that you can't do
it on your own.
It might be disability.
It might be death.
It might be divorce.
It might be, you get fired.
It might be-- so many things
can happen in our lives.
But as we look to others, look
to our friends and family,
co-workers--
all those people-- for help, we
can get through that next step.
But, guys, as we continue
to do those hard things,
we will be able to
overcome even the toughest
challenges in our life.
It might take years!
It took me four years of cross
country till I was any good.
It took me four years
of wrestling to make it
to the state championships.
But as we overcome
those challenges,
we're going to find
some strengths.
And honestly, now,
you've gotten to the top.
Now, you know you
can overcome it.
But you know what?
You're going to find some
other things that you can
do that are even more amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
I hope you remember--
I know you're not
going to remember
everything I said today.
You're going to remember
the crazy tricks
and the funny stories.
But I hope you remember
that nothing is impossible.
We all have some sort
of adaptive thing.
We all have a
challenge in our lives.
But we all can overcome
them one step at a time.
Thank you so much
for having me here.
Everybody, remember, get out
there, and have a great day,
and rise up.
Thank you so much.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]